ce dimanche dans le cortège de la
manifestation contre le mariage pour
tous 80000 ivelinois selon les
organisateurs des élus des parents mais
aussi des jeunes parmi eux Étienne
Bertier à 21 ans il assume sa position
de conservateur oui on pourrait dire les
jeunes sont pour le progrès en soi mais
pas n'importe quel progrès vraiment
réfléchir à construire un progrès et
voilà c'est pour ça je pense que cette
loi en tout cas cette loi nécessite plus
de concertation ça all très vite on a vu
que ça é un sujet cvant pour la France
pourquoi ne pas prendre plus de parce
que Madame Tobi a dit c'est un
changement de civilisation Clémence
baral en est à sa 10e manifestation
peut-être 15 elle ne les compte plus
pour elle c'est l'idéologie de Mai 68
qui est en cause alors pour que les
enfants aient droit à un père et une
mère elle est prête à jouer les contre
révolutionnaire on entre jeune on se dit
B on n pas tout seul dans dans nos
convictions ça fait ça fais vraiment
trop plaisir de voir qu'on est toute une
génération qui se lève et et c'est
clairement c'est le moteur à chaque fois
on se dit voilà on va tout le monde on
est pas seul dansiction il y a pas que
les vieux qui sont avec cette pensée là
on est on est tout G qui se lève c'est
juste trop beau et c'est alors même si
la loi a été promulgué les jeunes
activistes espèrent encore que le
président la retire comme cela avait été
le cas en 2006 et 1984 pour les lois du
CPE et de l'école libre